so do you think obama made it worse
definitely how so
uh he so when it came to trayvon martin
that the story between trayvon and
zimmerman is extremely complicated right
and trayvon zimmerman for instance is
hispanic he was like a
white hispanic guy so is kyle kyle oh
yeah
he's also hispanic but you know barack
obama's
whole uh perspective on it was the
left-wing perspective if i had a kid
he'd look like trayvon
instead of calling for unity and saying
you know we need to understand sometimes
these circumstances
are tragic unfortunate and violence and
death happens and that's why we need to
make sure this doesn't happen
and we need to we need to expand beyond
the people while respecting those who
lost their lives calling for justice
recognize
this is a systemic issue that needs to
be solved
what i mean what what i mean by systemic
is like in the instance of briana taylor
it's not about racism it's about no
knock warrants right so rand paul says
hey none of these
and i understand some people have some
you know good reasons for no knock
warrants
i'd prefer no i think they have to
announce themselves and they can
make a perimeter and this this you can't
because people have right to defend
themselves too
and you're creating a circumstance to
put potentially innocent people in
harm's way
so that's that that's one of the things
he could have done but more importantly
it was obama and biden during all of
that stuff they took
they consistently took the left-wing
view of everything the right was bad of
course it was
the national guard was deployed to
ferguson they
you know they sent out police very much
so under obama's watch
racial tensions escalated particularly
with black lives matter
see see people have a hard time
believing me when i tell them that i'm
like i really think that obama did more
to undermine race relations in this
country than you could possibly imagine
that the
first black president would and people
are like are you crazy but i i don't
think it's that
much though you don't think it was like
like okay so listen
off the top of my head it's the thing he
mentioned trayvon and it's very much
we're in ferguson and stuff
yeah yeah yeah but i don't think it's
trump's
i don't think it's trump's fault and i
don't think it was obama's fault
i think there's definitely things that
trump and obama said or did that
contribute they're the president of
course
but i think the fault of these issues
for the most part lands in localities
it lands in the media and for the most
part the media and the activists
okay but do you think that because the
media was entirely in obama's pocket
do you think that they gave him more
credence than he might have even
necessarily deserved when he was saying
his race basis absolutely yeah way more
than that
trump because they go after trump they
fan the flames of this the media
in my opinion is the biggest player here
and i think social media as well for
instance
cassandra fairbanks got suspended from
twitter she's a conservative journalist
because she tweeted that cal rittenhouse
did nothing wrong
right they suspended her for an opinion
over an individual
who has not been convicted yet
antifa is actively organizing on the
platform right
social media is to blame media in
general is to blame
and they go hand in hand these fake news
journalists defend censorship
they say but they they lie oh the lies
man
because how'd your fair banks get
suspended and they say there's no bias
against conservatives
it's like well hold on antifa is on the
platform saying hey everyone we're
meeting here bring sticks
right like okay i'm exaggerating but
they'll be like bring supplies to help
defend you know the the the
the community that's okay so i would say
that the media wields even more power
than any almost any politician
yes absolutely how is that okay it's not
okay
well it's not so much whether it's okay
or it's not okay the issue is there's
they're unchecked
right anybody who dares challenge them
they smear
i mean i'm not gonna get into it but
gamergate for instance oh yeah
was very like from from my view of what
it was and i probably don't know a whole
lot about it
you get a bunch of people saying hey
these journalists are taking money
from the advertisers and then they're
writing bunk articles
and the next day they're like a bunch of
white supremacists are harassing us
uh-huh weird right yeah yeah that's
crazy so
look i'm i i already know that even
bringing it up i'm gonna get a bunch of
people being like here's what really
happened and the left is being like how
dare you defend
they still they still talk about
gamergate the left still says like
trump is the gamergate president or
whatever and it's like you know what you
know what's funny
um who was it who tweeted this it was
oliver darcy
claiming that the the right defending
written house is like the definition of
uh radicalization yes was that that was
him right with him so he's
cnn guy for sunday morning and i'm just
like okay let's play a game
let's uh define radicalization how about
do this can you can you google search
the word
we're gonna play a game okay yeah just
google radicalizations
definition what does google say okay it
says the action or process of causing
someone to adopt radical positions on
political or social issues wait this
sounds like okay go on
okay so uh radicalization that's time of
the game all right
is it radical to suggest border security
nope no because the democrats were in
favor of it
a decade ago i mean even hillary clinton
in the past election cycle was saying
we needed some kind of border security
okay okay is it radical to uh
suggests that we should bolster the
economy
bring factories back and help the middle
class get jobs absolutely not
okay uh i don't know what else do we got
is it is it uh radical to suggest
the united states should be able to
defend itself and that its allies should
pay their fair share
towards uh defense spending when we sent
our troops over to their jurisdiction no
it seems fair
yeah because we've been doing it for
decades right okay is it radical to
suggest we should remove our troops from
the middle east and from other
unnecessary endless wars
absolutely not no because the left has
been calling for it yep four decades
up until trump called for it is it
radical to suggest that we should
overhaul and abolish our private
health care system and replace it with
pure government spending yes
that's completely insanity that's an
over like okay maybe we can work
is it radical to suggest we should build
trains
and uh phase out airplane air travel and
ban
all fossil fuels so yes
yes because radical if if we got into
that we got into the definite
definition of radicalization but the
word radical the root word
especially of a change or action
relating to or affecting
fund the fundamental nature of something
far-reaching or thorough
okay so yes the whole plane's changing
is it is it radical to suggest
we should decriminalize border crossings
yeah is it radical to suggest
that we should no longer deport people
who enter the country illegally yeah
these are these things are all radical
compared to where america's been for the
past 200 years
and that is far-reaching right so
obviously we can go back in time and
talk about
you know they like to make these
arguments about when citizenship became
a thing and when borders became a thing
and they became things
and as far as as far as as long as i've
existed in this country we've had border
security and border patrol and
immigration services
it is radical to me as a regular
american to be told
abolish private health care which is
literally what bernie said i'm not
exaggerating
the green new deal banning fossil fuels
and a moratorium on deportations and
decriminalizing border crossings
and providing universal health care to
non-citizens i'm like that's psychotic
you want to inch towards this stuff i'll
be like okay
concessions can be made but to be like
right
wait what do you got so this is okay
yeah i'll let you finish what you're
thinking but
heather hang made this point a while ago
and this is something that jordan
peterson talked about a little bit
you don't fool with something that's
been in place for a very long time
unless you have an extremely
good reason for doing so because things
are in place
often for a reason i'm not talking about
flaws in our society like racism and
sexism and all that stuff
i'm talking about things like borders
things that every single country in the
world has
you mess with those kinds of things you
mess with the nuclear you mess with the
family
at your own peril these are things that
you definitely do not understand you do
not understand the implications of what
you're trying to do
and when you do radical things that's
exactly what you're doing and i know
without a doubt by looking at people
like aoc
that they're not thinking past stage one
this is why
it's it's fascinating to watch joe biden
when
i think he said something today do i
look like a dirty social
what do you say do i look like a radical
like a right yeah socialist or whatever
it's like i gotta be honest joe yes
a little bit i said earlier no and let
me make sure i can clarify this
no in the sense that joe biden looks
like a crotchety old man who has no idea
what's going on he looks
weak you're right but but you know i was
thinking about it
in terms of the conversation of
radicalization i mean joe biden has
agreed to a lot of bernie's proposals
not all of them he's not far left enough
but that's radical to regular americans
right
i mean it's mind-blowing to me i think i
think kamal actually walked this back
they said like who would be in favor of
abolishing private health care
she raised her hand right i remember
that in the initial in the early debates
and then she showed a public statement
like later that day or night or saying
oh actually no i don't want to do that i
remember this
it's radical to say you want to abolish
private
health care it is radical to say you
want to defund the
defund the police it is particularly
radical for the new york times to
publish an article saying yes we mean
abolish the police
so who are the radicals it's the left
so it's no surprise to go back to what i
was saying that we can have these
conversations
that we can get tremendous viewership
not just me but many other
uh channels and the media has no idea
it's happening
because they're in the radical bubble to
them
trump is far right because they're far
left whereas
trump's actually a moderate relative to
american policy yep they've radicalized
themselves
and you know it's real it's really sad i
was talking to a friend
and his first foray into the actual
through the fire like the the outside
what what can we call this basically
i think it was breitbart who said this
walk through the fire yep on the other
side there's freedom yeah andrew
breitbart yeah and so there are people
who are still
on the other side scared and they've not
seen outside they have not seen the
freedom
and they have not seen what's actually
going on and then as soon as they peek
their head out they're like ah what's
happening it's scary
it's cold and where am i it's like
you're on the beach dude
we're chilling you're on your own now
they like being in that in that cave
surrounded you know being told what to
do total to think
i imagine it this way all of these
people are sitting in a cave
and there's one person in the front of
that cave telling them here's what's
happening outside trust us there's fire
it'll burn you in this cave
kind of yeah i think that's what it is
is it plato's i think it is but the
general idea is
a bunch of people are being told if you
go outside the fire will burn you don't
do it just trust us and we'll tell you
and then you know do work for us it's
easy it's safe
and well it's it's i mean if you trust
people it makes sense
if you grew up with someone you know
always there for you
and they told you if you go outside
you'll die because the air is poison
and then you grow up and finally go
outside and you discover the air's not
poison
then you know rick and morty reference
by the way then you're like my whole
life is a lie what's happening and you
might have like a
you know what's the right word you might
have a
an intense reaction you'll have an
existential crisis for sure yeah so a
lot of people who go through this
you know they probably resisted like
when we were talking to brandon strzok
from walk away
and he said that he did all this
research and he was willing to let it
all go
if rachel maddow produced some hard
evidence against trump like
he had watched all these videos he had
seen that they were lying about trump
and then rachel maddow said i got his
tax return he's like okay
i will ignore everything i read if she
has something that was such an
insight because it was like i understand
that feeling because i've i've
made some hard changes in my own
thinking and i've been like you know
what it would be easier if this weren't
true
i would like this to not be true but it
is i i i totally get that
because i think about this but i guess
you know what
one of my advantages it is is a bit of
like
existential nihilism in a sense where
i feel like you should go through life
with a smile on your face
because i actually you know i wonder if
this is kind of like faith in a sense
where it's like i feel that there is a
plan a purpose
that the world is the world is what it
is
you're not no one you you deserve
nothing right
you can work hard and then a rock can
fall in your head and kill you you know
so i go through life under the under the
like this view i've i've often thought
about
like if my channels got banned right oh
yeah i know you think about that all the
time
and i just laugh and i'd be like well
what can you do about it
and i think this comes from you know
when i was younger i remember my dad
telling me
if he was telling me about about the
great depression right and now people
were
killing themselves because they lost all
their money in the stock market and
stuff and i was like why would they do
that he's like
if you made a million bucks and lost it
overnight you'd be angry too and i'm no
i wouldn't i'd be like wow i had a
million bucks how about that well what
do i have to do now to get what i need
if you go through life with that kind of
view then
you're not going to be this negative
angry person
who's refusing to accept reality right
so here's the ultimate point i'm trying
to make
when i see news and it's like
you know donald trump did a bad thing
cause the orange man is bad
my reaction isn't like how dare they lie
about trump i go like
i wonder if this one's true right
probably isn't but i'm going to read it
anyway and then
there we go it's not true so i i
definitely develop a bias in the sense
where it's like
the media lies so much i just can't give
them the benefit of the doubt
but if something bad came out you know
about trump or trump supporters i'd just
be like uh-huh
i just don't care you you can't expect
that your tribe is perfect you can't
expect the world is perfect
you can work as hard as you want and
while i do believe meritocracy is
the best way to go about you know
building
functioning systems you could be the
greatest guy in the world doing all the
hardest work in the world and then
someone could walk up and just like
crack you over there with a bat and
you're gone yep so it's just
you you live your life day to day and
you accept that there's ups and there's
downs
if bad news comes out many people refuse
to accept it i think because they're
scared
survivability is an issue i don't know
if you've ever read the poem that's
called if by rudyard kipling nope
he talks about um he says if you can uh
if you can talk with crowds and keep
your virtue or walk with kings and not
lose the common touch
if neither foes nor loving friends can
hurt you if all men count with you but
none too much
you're basically this is what makes you
a man of character
if you look at people and you're like
you know what it doesn't matter what
they do to me
this is a stoic teaching at this point
it doesn't matter what they do to me it
only matters what i do and whether i
make something of myself and if i lose
everything
so what that's the way it is sometimes
and and that's
probably the most well-rounded
philosophy you can have when you're
looking at this crazy world that's
currently on fire and insane
like what else are you supposed to do be
a little bit nihilistic care about the
people around you
do the best you can and look for truth
like what's better i think i got lucky
at good parents
yeah i think you're right cause i
remember uh i remember
i was late for school once because we
lived on the south side of chicago and
there's trains that go through the south
side
and the trains man wow they're long you
ever waited to train it's like the
freight and you like turn your engine
off on your car cause you're like i'm
gonna be here for 20 minutes right
and so i remember going to school and
the train blocked me and i got i was
late
and then i was like you know i come home
and my dad was like
you know i was like oh i was late you
got to sign a form or something i can't
remember exactly what we used to do back
then
but he was like well he's like this is
your fault like why would why were you
late and i was like it wasn't my fault
there's a train and he goes you knew the
train tracks were there it was your
fault
if you know the tracks are there and you
know the trains are there then you need
to prepare for the trains
and i was like oh yeah that's true huh
yeah oh yeah i guess you're right i
can't change the train schedules right
and i knew the trains come through in
the mornings i should have properly
planned ahead
i used to drive with people who would
get mad at red lights they were like
well the light would turn green and they
were like why are we moving yet i'm like
because the car in front of you
isn't moving yet and there is nothing
you can do about that but you can wait
until that car starts moving and then
you can go and it's great that's that's
really it's like it's like running into
a wall
what does this remind me of you need to
let go you need to
it's it's what am i thinking of i was
thinking it's like some some uh
martial arts movie where he's explaining
like going with the flow
and having the like like you're in a
river
you know and it's you're you're flowing
downstream and you can try and resist it
or you can steer yourself and use that
speed and control it a better way to
explain it is
i can't control the wind but i can't
adjust my sails exactly stop
getting so mad all the time right
exactly i think i think if you chill
and a lot of these people aren't that's
why they have these these crises of
character
when news comes out about trump it's
also why i think we're experiencing what
we are with
with trump derangement syndrome media
people can't
accept in their world trump is the evil
bad man
therefore no matter what happens they
view it through the lines of trump being
evil bad man
and so what ends up happening is they
develop it's almost amazing
how their brains are put stitched
together at this point because it's kind
of like if you took
i don't know a motor scooter and duct
taped it to
uh a car and then put like bike pedals
on it
you wouldn't expect to be able to drive
you're like what is this like how do you
actually make it move yeah but they've
somehow stitched together
these broken frankenstein thing this
frankenstein world view
and turned it into some kind of
functioning system where they can still
live breathe and eat
and but what i mean to say you know
because i it is
a bit silly but you'll simultaneously be
like trump is inciting violence why
won't he stop this
how dare he send out police to stop this
yep like how do you have that in your
brain at the exact same time
i tweeted this earlier i said 2020 is a
year of why won't this fascist dictator
send
troops to drop this peaceful writing or
something or why won't this fascist
dictator seize all our guns
exactly or here's an article about a one
uh here's an interview with a woman
who wrote a book called in defense of
looting by the way the looting is
trump's fault by the way it's not
happening at all and it's entirely
peaceful that's great i love just
right wow that that that reminds me of
that david firth
uh the the news hasn't happened yet
if you guys haven't seen david firth
stuff you really gotta watch it because
the dude's a genius
weird but but yeah yeah he has a segment
called the news hasn't happened yet
and that so reminds me of it's like the
riots are peaceful the fires
aren't really that bad protesters
burning down buildings are also peaceful
trump is inciting this he didn't
actually say anything to incite it and
he's sending out troops because he's a
fascist but the troops actually aren't
there and looting is actually a good
thing
yes all of these things no one sees any
issue with this at all
except maybe us it's you know so i guess
the way i put it though it has to
actually be the most negative
interpretation
always right trump is trump trump's
trying to send out gestapo secret police
to round up protesters
while he's inciting the violence and he
won't stop the violence because it's
trump's america
and looting is good because the
protesters are doing it and it's
reparations
you know what's funny to me is if you
sat them down and you asked them to
explain what they were
thinking you know they wouldn't be able
to and that
baffles me how do you go through life
without being able to explain what you
think
well here it is right yeah they're how
do you break people out of this
this broken world view there's nothing
to break them into well no no there is
like to get them out
and show them like so i was talking to a
friend of mine who was very much like
experiencing their first time through
the flames and i sent him an article and
they're like huh
and you can clearly see when people
start to realize like wait a minute
like what is what is this all about the
things i was reading before
said this that the orange man is bad and
i'm like
here's a video watch the video just
watch trump speak one time
i've mentioned this several times but
having gone to trump's rallies early on
i think inoculated me from trump
arrangement syndrome because it changed
my assumptions
i met trump supporters immediately i
watched trump speak immediately
and then when i saw something in the
news i was like i didn't even say that
or whatever yeah
and but i was working for companies
experiencing them live so you know
that's great
yeah yeah i always tell people if you
think that you know what the media is
doing you should just watch trump speak
and then watch what they say about it
because i always kind of place my bets
i'm like which way are they going to go
with this are they going to go two
different ways
different outlets are going to say
different things about the same thing
that was exactly they do they do
they totally do it's great every time do
you see the uh let me see if i can find
it
it's an old instagram post
where uh it wasn't i i didn't put this
tweet together but i wasn't able to
properly attribute the photo because it
was put together by someone with a very
offensive name that would get me banned
from instagram
oh okay so i was like i don't i can't
even say the name because
it's going to result in liking a man but
check this out oh yeah
so this is a a post i put on instagram
and i
i think i think i mentioned this i don't
know whatever
but anyway you've got two screens this
is amazing this is in a gym
on the left you've got cbs sondlin
confirms a quid pro quo this is in
reference to gordon sondelin testifying
about donald trump and ukraine
on the right is fox news quote i want
nothing sondlin confirms trump told him
no quid pro quo
you quite literally have two different
news outlets reporting
two different things being confirmed
they have the same image on the screen
yep they have well it's exactly
yeah so here's what i said i said uh two
different
two different realities and it's
impossible to convince people what's
true but i'll try anyway sanlin did not
confirm quid pro quo he stated that he
presumed there was one but received no
direct orders
and heard nothing of this from any other
staffer he did confirm that donald trump
said i want nothing
silent's testimony of a presumed quid
pro quo was contradicted by two other
officials
trump confirmed the i want nothing call
maybe that's journalism
you know to offer differing viewpoints
no no no
no to actually do what i just did and
say straight up yeah
you've got these two screens fox news
was correct cbs
lied right so just pick which is that's
crazy man and so what happens is when
you have this for four years
and people build a world view off of
this you can't change that
because they'll go insane they'll have
they'll have a nervous breakdown well
that's what i mean there's nothing to
pop them out of like there's nothing to
to pop them into out of their little
bubble where do you go from there
they've been building this for years and
there's there's
nothing and if you sit them that's what
i mean if you sit them down and ask them
to explain what they're thinking
they have nothing this feels like a
grand experiment in like
mass uh um delusional
mass like media induced paranoid
delusional
complexity yeah like
that woman we talked about last week
where she's like trump is an autocrat
trying to take over and
putin's helping him it's like dude
you're crazy go watch a movie or
something
yeah that's crazy like how about donald
trump is
a you know kind of a pompous flawed
president yeah
getting stuff done yeah yeah yeah yeah
i uh seth macfarlane tweeted something
about
voting for biden and i was just thinking
to myself like there's no way he really
means this
seth is smart he's a smart guy he's got
14 million followers
does he like it's just a game to him
he's like well you know trump is bad
vote for bad i'm like nobody
who's paying attention thinks that biden
is better than trump
nobody's paying attention the people who
are wrapped up in bubble world where
they're watching fake news
certainly think trump is like a demon
from outer space
who or like you know the child of a
demon and an alien or something trying
to eat human beings and destroy the
planet he's an autocrat
yeah and you know he's responsible for
the the riots
while refusing to do anything whatever i
i don't think any sane person who
watches real news and does research
is thinking biden makes more sense the
dude just did like his first
rally in what like 100 days or some
ridiculous number
and he couldn't speak properly and it's
remarkable you turn on cnn and they're
like
trump supporters for some reason think
biden can't speak and i'm like have you
watched his rallies
nobody is suggesting that the entire
hour he spoke was him just like
teeth falling out i mean but he gaffs
yeah all the time
yeah that one wasn't a gaff dude when he
was like can you
believe in a year we had you know 100
year
it's you know we we more deaths in 100
years than a year and i'm like
i don't know what you're trying to say
dude i'm telling you man nursing home
flashbacks
yeah yeah it's really sad man it's too
bad well
i don't know what to ex i don't know i
don't know what we do other than maybe
we do just stay home make money and uh
and vote i think you should keep
journalisming the journalists
i mean watching the watchmen yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you